one day the last star will die and the
universe will turn dark forever it will
probably be a red dwarf a tiny kind of
star that's also one of our best bets to
find alien life and might be the last
home of humanity before the universe
becomes uninhabitable so what do we know
about them and why are they our last
hope at least 70% of stars in the
universe are red dwarfs they are the
tanja stars out there with only about 7
to 50% of the mass of our Sun not that
much bigger than our planet Jupiter
which is still huge though they are also
very dim it's impossible to see them
with the naked eye you've never seen one
in the night sky even with all our
technology we can only clearly observe
red dwarfs in our neighborhood
approximately 20 of the 30 stars close
to Earth are red dwarfs like all stars
red dwarfs fuse hydrogen into helium but
while more massive stars accumulate all
the fuse helium in their cores red
dwarfs stay convective meaning that the
helium and hydrogen constantly makes so
they use up their fuel incredibly slowly
before they're extinguished red dwarfs
burn so slowly that that average
lifespan is between 1 and 10 trillion
years by comparison the Sun will survive
for another five billion years because
the universe is only thirteen point
seven five billion years old not a
single red dwarf has reached later
development stages every single one of
the trillions that exists is still a
baby speaking of babies the smallest
star in the entire universe is also a
red dwarf because small red dwarfs are
right on the verge of being a star at
all just a tiny bit less hydrogen and
they are mere brown dwarfs failed stars
that cannot sustain a fusion reaction
for
so what about aliens or a new home for
humanity since our son will die one day
we'll eventually need to look for a new
home and where there are habitable
planets there might also be aliens the
Kepler space observatory found that at
least half of all red dwarfs host rock
planets between half and four times the
mass of our earth many of them are in
the habitable zone the area around a
star where water can be liquid but since
red dwarfs burn at relatively cold
temperatures a planet would need to be
really close to be hospitable probably
as close as mercury to our Sun or even
closer which brings with it all kinds of
problems for example a planet this close
to a star would probably be tightly
locked
meaning the same side would always face
it this side would be incredibly hot
while the shadow side would be frozen
which makes it hard for life to develop
although a planet with a big enough
ocean might be able to distribute the
star's energy and create some kind of
stability all the gravitational forces
of the red dwarf could squeeze the
planets and heat it up so much but it
might lose all its water over time these
planets could end up like Venus a hot
burning hell another problem is that
many red dwarfs vary in their energy
output they can be covered in star spots
that condemn their emitted light by up
to 40% for months which would cause
oceans on planets to freeze over at
other times they can emit powerful solar
flares sudden outbursts of energy
incredibly powerful these red dwarfs
could double their brightness in minutes
which could strip away sizable portions
of a planet's atmosphere and burn it
rendering its sterile on the other hand
their extremely long lifespan is a big
plus a red dwarf with just moderate
levels of activity could be an amazing
place for a planet for the hosts life
life on Earth has existed for about four
billion years and we have about a
billion years left before the Sun
becomes so hot the complex life on Earth
will become impossible we will either
die out or leave earth and look for a
new home we could build a civilization
for potentially trillions of years
around a red dwarf with the right
conditions about 5% of the red dwarfs in
the Milky Way may host habitable roughly
earth sized planets that would be more
than four billion in total but life may
not even need a planet like Earth
candidates for life around a red dwarf
maybe the moons of gas giants also
called super Earths rady massive rocky
planets although there are an estimated
60 billion potentially habitable planets
around red dwarfs and that's in the
Milky Way alone so red dwarfs might
become really important for our survival
in the future but everything has to die
at some point even red dwarfs when in
trillions of years the life of the last
red dwarf in the universe is about to
end it will not be a very spectacular
event as its hydrogen runs out it
shrinks becoming a blue dwarf burning
out completely after its fuel is spent
it's transformed into a white dwarf an
object about as small as Earth packed
very densely and made of degenerate
gases mostly of helium-4 nuclei having
no more source of energy it will cool
extremely slowly over trillions of years
until it becomes its final form a cold
black dwarf white and black dwarfs are
so fascinating that they deserve their
own video anyway it's going to be a long
time before the last stars in the
universe vanish it's kind of uplifting
to know that if humanity succeeds in
venturing into space we have plenty
time before the universe turns out the
lights our videos are made thanks to
your support on patreon.com if you want
to help us make more of them we really
appreciate your support